[Music]
good evening thanks for coming today
we're going to go over chess tactics all
the examples tonight are going to be
about the Queen and Bishop attacking the
point King works seven so all these
examples are taken by the chest book the
game of chess by ciguatera shirt he's a
German he contended for the World
Championship and he wrote his book in
1935 he didn't win the World
Championship but he he was good enough
to contend for it in a match and he was
the chess amateur he was a doctor by his
side he made his living anyway he made
these great examples so I've been going
through these each week we go through a
different set of examples so tonight
we're gonna again go through how the
Queen and Bishop can attack the King
works seven pawn and work through some
examples like that but our first example
here white wins you can see that the
bishop on d3 is attacking the h7 pawn as
is the Queen on h3 it's White's move
white could win the pawn with Queen
takes pawn check or Bishop takes pawn
check also notice that the white work
that's on a1 can join the attack by
moving up to III two squares up and then
can move over two squares to the G three
square and that would be check on the
black King so black is in dire straits
here see how blacks Bishop is on a it's
a white square bishop and it's blocked
by his pawn on e6 also notice that black
has double pawns on the King side and
the pawns actually blocked the Queen
from moving over to the King side to
help protect the King side now blacks
works are not well placed either they're
both behind pawns so blacks pieces are
doing nothing
and black is pretty helpless now the one
thing to notice that about blacks king
if white takes that pawn with check with
either Queen or Bishop the King can move
over to one square to f8 and then can
escape checkmate
by moving up to e7 behind his pawns so
the question for the audience is what's
the best way for white to win the game
it's White's white to move and win
what's the best move what's your guess
very good that is absolutely the correct
idea now the threat is Bishop takes pawn
check and the King has to go over to the
h-file we can bring the bishop back the
King goes back to g8 and then the rook
can come up and that would lead to
checkmate so what black tries he tries
to block the bishop line with f5 now
what's White's white needs another
winning move here what's the correct
move for a white to continue the attack
yeah we're t3 absolutely right it brings
the rook up and the threat is Ric to the
3rd and that would be checkmate then on
g7 the King moves in the corner and the
Queen would move up to g7 checkmate now
there's no good way for black to get out
of it so the author had Queen here but
oh so the Queen went to d4 see how it
guards the checkmate square it works
back toward the black King and guards
the g7 square guarding checkmate but it
doesn't do any good because with this
move white attacks the Queen and the
Queen can't stay on that diagonal and it
can no longer and if the Queen moves off
the diagonal then work to g3 check and
then it's checkmate on g7 so the winning
move is that last move c3 attacking the
Queen and that's that's the end of this
example so if the Queen were to go back
to g7 to try to trade Queens well then
work the g3 pins the Queen against the
king and wins the Queen so so that's the
end of that example this is tricky I
will tell you that right off the bat
this is a tricky it's it's white to play
in checkmate but it's very tricky would
anyone like to guess what White's
winning move is
so Knight takes pawn and if Queen takes
Knight you move the rook over and pin
the Queen to the king right yeah Oh II
seven check that's the right move Knight
here check Black has to do Queen takes
Knight now what's the move
no you're on the right track though just
see if you can find the winning move now
there's a a great winning move to follow
up with what do you think Queen to h5
then he has pawn takes rook any other
ideas
don't be afraid to sacrifice pieces in
these examples okay Jason what do you
think right Brooke h8 King takes now you
get the C that opened the line for the
Queen to come in and it got rid of the
rook which was blocking the White Queen
now the Queen and Bishop are attacking
h7 so you drop your the Queen goes there
the King goes up and like it's checkmate
with Bishop to g6 checkmate
so that was tricky you did good to find
that 97 move though that was a difficult
move to find I thought okay well
obviously White is the one attacking
because his queen is on each five near
the black King his bishops on d3
his knights on h5 attacking the g3
square see how the Queen and the night
but not g3 the g6 square the square
right in front of the black king and
Noda and this white knight on c4 is
really not doing anything so don't worry
about the knight on c4 now the work on
e1 can move into the attack along that
efile he can go up all the way to e6 the
pawns protected a couple times but it's
a possibility he can move up along the
e-file and maybe move over to the F file
at some point now the white rook on a1
is not doing anything so you can
disregard that rook
similarly the white pawns are not in
contact with black pawns so you can
disregard any pawn moves and it's white
to play and win this is also tricky does
anyone see a good move for white alright
let's look at Knight to g6
how about pawn takes knight threatening
pawn takes Queen what oh then you would
have a queen check and you'd have Queen
to h7 mate good alright so we have to
find something else Knight g6
we can't take it and you're threatening
our rook if you do Knight to g6 I'm
going to take my knight on d5 and
retreat to f6 and attack your queen and
if you move the Queen away then I can
take your knight on g6 it it's and you
want to have Queen takes pawn check so I
think Knight to f6 refutes Knight to g6
does anyone have another move for white
this is tricky so I just go ahead with
it
white sacrifices his rook now obviously
if pawn takes rook it frees up the g6
squared we already looked that's
checkmate Queen to g6 check King to h8
Queen h7 is checkmate so he can't do
pawn takes rook now the other choice is
Knight takes rook so what happens if
Knight takes rook well let's let's go on
and he does tonight takes rook now
there's a strong attacking continuation
for white does anybody see what white
should do
what do you see that's the right move
Knight to f5 check
notice that the knight attacks the King
and the knight attack ch6 pawn as does
the White Queen so we're going to break
through on the King work file probably
with Queen takes pawn check next move
let's see what black does black just
retreats now it looks like we could do
Queen takes pawn and that would threaten
Queen to Knight 7 checkmate
Knight takes even first Queen takes
threatening Queen to h7 checkmate right
I can move my pawn from f7 to f5 and
block the bishop and my queen on e7 will
protect and can slide along in front of
the king and protect the King from any
Queen checks so that's a good idea but
it there's a defense so 90 X Bishop
check isn't it is there a stronger move
for a White Queen takes pawn is not
strong enough either I don't think
because black can move the bishop on e7
f6 in guard the g7 square and besides he
doesn't really threaten Queen d2 g7 is
not checkmate anyway cuz the knight on
East 6th guards g7 so Queen takes pawn
isn't the move what's the next move for
white to try Knight takes h h6 check say
that forces the King if he goes off he
can't go over to the well he could go
over to the rook file but then we get a
discovered check with our Knight that
should win something for us
so he buddy has to go back up to g7
which he does
now we check and drive him back but
notice he no longer has that pawn on h6
we took it so now the Queen and the
bishop are pointing to 8 7 but the
Knights blocking it so now Knight takes
bishop check wins something takes and
then it's Queen down checkmate ok now in
this case the author decides to let
black win a game
so blacks Bishop is on d6 see how it's
hitting the pawn on h2 and the work is
on h6 attacking along the rook file and
the queen is ready to come in on h4 but
temporarily it's you can't do Queen h4
cuz the knight guards the h4 square
anyway
Oh black is attacking with the rook the
knight on e4 the bishop on d6 and the
Queen who sees the winning move for
black any guesses
check sacrificing the bishop but drawing
the night away from the h4 square night
takes now what's the winning move go
ahead right and if the knight moves its
queen the h1 checkmate right and Ken
whiteford sure but we can then do Queen
to h1 checkmate so there's nothing
nothing for white to do black wins okay
we're back to white winning the white
bishop on d3 attacks the pawn on h7 the
white queen on d1 can move to h5 at an
opportune moment and attack the alumna
h-file the white rook is on b3 so it's
been moved up three squares and can move
over to the King side and join in the
attack
that's called a rook lifts by the way
when you move your ruck up three two
squares to the third and you want to
move it over to the right side in front
of the King side pawns but the rook
can't get over there right away because
the two bishops are blocking the rook
now the white rook on King Bishop will
on f1 is not doing anything and can't
move because the black bishop guards to
the e1 square so that work on f1 is out
of it all the pawns aren't in context so
there's no pawn moves for either side so
the move is going to be by the Queen the
two white bishops and the white rook and
black is going to try to hold his
position together
also notice that the white bishop on e3
is on a black square and has the
possible move at some point Bishop to c5
attacking the black work on f8 now black
would have to move his rook over to e8
or he would lose a rook for a bishop
which would be bad anyway those are the
possibilities who in the audience would
like to guess what the right move is for
white it's not actually Queen to h5 that
would threaten checkmate black could
play g6 attack the Queen and block the
bishop diagonal and stop checkmate any
other guesses
well I give you as remember I said that
the two bishops block the rook right and
I said the bishop on e3 on the black
square could move out of the rooks way
and attack the black work so let's start
with that move Bishop to c5 see we gain
a move
we got the bishop out of the way of that
rook and we're attacking the black rook
so black has to move to e8 so we gained
a move and we got our Bishop out of the
way and the bishops done a very good
square there too
okay now that the the only thing
preventing the work from sliding over is
the bishop on d3 who would like to
suggest a move for white right
absolutely correct
that's a bishop sacrifice leading to the
win of a game by attacking on the Queen
rook file following up with the Queen
and the rook so let's see what happens
King takes Queen to h5 check the only
move rook h3 threatening Queen down
checkmate he had to move the pawn up to
f6 too so the King has an escape square
there are two winning moves for white
here who would like to guess what one of
those two moves is
let me point out that the White Queen is
attacking the rook on e8 that rook is
only protected by the Queen can we drive
the Queen away from the rook what do you
think rook to d1 is one of the winning
moves if the Queen the Queen can't move
so the only move is to block the attack
on the Queen with Bishop to d7 so rook
to d1 Bishop to d7 the move is Queen in
King to f7 now we swing our rook to g3
see how the rook and Queen attack the
pawn on g7 now if he boosts his rook on
EA to g8 see how it blocks the King from
moving back to the white square of g8 so
if it's worth the g8 to protect the pawn
we just do queen of g6 is checkmate
Queen the g6 is checkmate then he can't
move the pawn we block the bot so they
can't move the rook no the Queen guards
that Square
the the only move that the author
si-jess is to move this pawn up see that
gives the king in xscape square he can
go to that white square e six now well
the Queen goes here the king goes here
if he goes to g8 see how the Queen and
the rook are lined up and the Queen can
take the pawn on g7 would be checkmate
so the King has to go up here and now
there's a checkmate who sees the
checkmate move anybody right to d6
oh it's not checkmate he can move King
back yeah then he takes the pawn and
that's checkmate the King can't move
anywhere so we worked at d1 that was
very good
now there's one other way to win and
it's a little trickier the rook to d1 I
think I might have seen work the d1 but
the trickier way is you drop your queen
in now you don't threaten any checkmate
right away but what you're threatening
is you can move the work up to h7 next
move and threaten Queen takes pawn
checkmate
so let's see what can he do then the
author says if that bishop moves to a6
threatening Bishop takes rook we don't
worry about losing the rook we play our
work 2h7 threatening checkmate
so let's digress a little bit in here
Bishop here rook here Queen here to
block the checkmate now there's a pretty
winning move for white does anybody see
the winning move for white h5 yeah right
now see how the Queen guards the escape
square from the king and the threat is
rook to h8 checkmate the only move is to
move the pawn up and we have a couple
ways to win one is work here King here
and Queen here is checkmate okay so
Queen to g6
we just looked at the bishop to a6 now
another defense is black can try f5 it
gives the King in escape square maybe he
can go up to f6 at some point now the
next move it for the best move for white
is tricky remember the white queen is
attacking the black work so the black
Queen can't move away from protecting
the rook does that suggest
can we move one of our pieces to attack
with the Queen the g7 pawn does anybody
see that move Bishop to d4 threatening
Queen takes
notice that queen up doesn't work as we
just do Bishop takes pawn Queen takes
and that leaves the rook undefended
again so the best black can do is pawn
up now we drop the work in and we
threaten checkmate Queen takes pawn
check best move for black is to defend
the checkmate and offer the trade of
Queens notice that the black queen left
the rook undefended but we moved our
work to h7 so if I take the black rook
the King can take our work that's why
the Queen could move up and stop the
checkmate there's a winning move though
it's not Queen takes for a check does
anybody see the winning move yeah where
it takes g7 Queen takes Queen here King
here and now we get this important pawn
and look how naked the white King is
there are no pawns in front of the white
king and we have a bishop in Queen now
our works not doing much for the attack
so let's see what happens can that black
Queen move anywhere
if the Queen moves to g6 to try to trade
Queens we would have Queen the h8 would
be checkmate
now the Queen could try to drop back to
g8 to defend to try to trade Queens so
let's look at that for just a second
let's say Queen here new variation all
right let's see Queen to h5 looks like
we're getting making excellent headway
yeah that's that's an excellent way all
right
so Queen the g8 testin do anything back
here the author says the best move for
black is to do Bishop to e6 that lets
the work out counter attacks the Queen
now it white can take the rook or the
bishop if he takes the rook then black
can take the bishop and black would have
two bishops against the rook so that
it's probably better to take the bishop
that now the materials even but white is
the head with pawns so white takes the
bishop Queen has to move up here Queen
down here check King to g8 now the Queen
drops back here see how it attacks the
bishop
that's undefended so the bishop retreats
now the work comes over joining the
attack
so I don't think I'll go any further
with it white wins but you can see that
black has three pawns they're all
isolated and white has five pawns
White's
two pawns up notice that they have the
bishops are the same color and the black
King is open to attack Queen to b3 check
and rook to d7 so black can't defend the
position but let's go on to the next
example
because we digressed a little bit from
what the author is trying to show us
this is clearly white is going to win
again with C he has his bishop on d3 and
it's aiming toward that pawn on h7
notice that the queen is on the dagger
now can go to h5 to help the bishop
notice that the knight on f3 can move to
g4 where it attacks h7 and if bishop
takes the knight it would open up the
rook file for the white work by pawn
takes Bishop
that would be an extremely strong attack
down the rook file against Blacks king
position now the white knight on c3
doesn't really do anything nor does the
white work on a1 they're out of it but
the white bishop and the queen and the
knight in the work and the pawn on h4
those are are attacking also we have a
pawn on e4 we can advance it one Square
and force the black bishop to retreat
from the black bishops and a decent
defending square on f6 so we can start
off our attack with pawn to e5 forces
the black bishop and look it blocks the
white bishop on b7 behind his own pawns
if black could have done pawn takes upon
C it would have opened up that diagonal
for the
like bishop and could have forced some
trade of a knight or bishop and reduced
White's attack so the starting move on
this attack is 'if i've forcing the
bishop back now we've reached the
position where we have the sacrificial
attack who would like to see just the
winning move for white one Knight to g5
isn't a bad move but it's not doesn't
sacrifice anything and it's not the best
way to continue the attack what do you
think
yes Bishop takes King takes now what
Knight g5 now if Bishop takes pawn takes
opens up the rook and the Queen can come
up to h5 and finish black off so he
can't do Bishop takes Knight can he move
his King back to g8 what does white do
if he moves his King back to g8 yeah and
what's our threat after you Queen to h5
what's White's threat there checkmate
right so black would be helpless he
can't go to g8 what's the only move left
for black why could go to h8 but then I
can move my Queen to h5 check King has
to move over to g1 and i have Queen to
h7 checkmate h6 or g6
let's look at h6 first that's what the
author says is best now now it gets
tricky this is a difficult to win for
white this who who sees the best
attacking a continuation for white
there's a good move for a white does
anybody see a good move
well he could just take it ya know we
need the knight there because the knight
gives us attacks on the f7 pawn the e6
pawn and if our Queen can get there like
Queen a d3 we might threaten Queen h7
would be checkmate so we need to keep
the knight on the board
yeah Queen to d2 see how we can take
advantage of the black King position by
lining or queen up on the King
threatening Knight takes pawn check
which would win the Queen the black
Queen and he can't do Bishop takes
Knight because pawn takes pawn would be
double check and then we would have the
rook joining the attack and we could put
our queen on d3 check he could take the
pawn I could it'd be all over all right
well let's go on the author says the
best move is to get the Queen so he give
up the pawn with white could now play
Knight takes pawn discovered check the
King moves back and then white could
take the rook with the knight and the
Queen would probably take back or maybe
the bishop but the author says that that
would actually white wouldn't would run
out of attacking chances after that it
would even up the material because he
would have won giving up two pieces but
he would have gotten two pawns and a
rook two pawns in the work is seven
points two pieces is six so white might
have a slight advantage but there's a
stronger continuation he can leave that
discovered check hang there for a while
so white needs to bring up more pieces
to attack so the author says the best
move is just castles Queen side
now that brings the the work that was on
a1 now is on d1 and can join the other
work in the attack and see how black
can't do anything relax
Bishop on b7 is blocked by his own pawns
his Knight is undeveloped his bishop
tamp black scored bishop on e7 can't
move anywhere
the Queen is blocked by the bishop and
the pawn on e6 and the black that black
work is in the corner and that works not
doing anything so black can't really
make any threats even though he's a
piece up so black tries to develop he
mousses Knight over to a6 white takes
his time he moves the King over he
wanted to get the King away from this
diagonal because the bishop would have
an attack against the King again White
has plenty of time so he's not in a
hurry
black shoves his F pawn up to block to
get some space and to block the white
pawns yep on passant now a rook takes so
now Knight takes bond checked by a white
discovered check doesn't win the rook
anymore white shoves his pawn up to g4
now he has two pawns
I see how the pawn at G 4 and H 4 or 1
square away from attacking the black
King notice that the black key can't
escape he can move to g6 but the Queen
that could always go here and check him
and drive him back so not only would
Queen here check King back then we'd
have Queen to h7 would be check
mate so blacks King is stuck so he tries
to bring the Queen over to guard some
squares around the King now we bring the
work from d1 see how the rook and Knight
are attacking the pawn the knight is
attacking this pawn and this Rick is
attacking the pawn and we're threatened
the kind of threatening Knight takes
pawn
once the Knights out of the way we would
be threatening pawn here check forking
the king and rook but I can't do much so
he retreats the knight I think we could
have done Knight takes pawn and tried
for the pawn fork I was talking about
but the author has h5 now the bishop
comes up now we take the pawn
notice that we're threatening pawn to g5
check forking the rook and King and that
we would win the work for a pawn so we
would win the game man the Kings in
check even stronger so the King has to
retreat oh now we can shove our pawn to
h6 pawn takes pawn I'll pawn the g5
forks the work and the h6 pawn rook has
to move over now the Queen comes up pins
the rook the thread is Rick takes pawn
on h6 check the knight comes back to
defend the rook and try to trade off the
knight Knight takes Knight Bishop takes
oh ok so we did Knight takes Knight now
he can't do Queen takes Knight because
he needs his Queen to defend the
rook you see if Queen takes Knight I do
Rick takes pawn check this works pinned
so the King moves and then they would
have Queen takes her a checkmate so he
has to give up his queen and now we have
our work on a one on the Queen we take
the Queen and and white wins because
let's see there's a rook a white work of
black where account offset there's a
knight so black has a work in a bishop
against the Queen but White has an extra
pawn and has a strong attack so there's
nothing that black can do
well what there's only one move let's go
ahead and play it
Queen to f5 so the Queen came up and now
the threat is Queen to f7 check and that
would win the rook on e one and there's
no good defense for black well I mean II
eight I'm sorry the the threat is Queen
to f7 check and Queen takes work on e8
not II won anyway there's more examples
but usually this is a we've gone through
enough examples for now
next week I'll finish up the ones we
didn't get
[Music]